les fours crématoires ne chômait ni jour
ni nuit et le cycle recommence est avec
l'habillage des nouveaux arrivés à
dachau où on faisait de la mort à la
chair les images sont rares difficile à
supporter le camp de concentration de
dachau vient d'être libéré par l'armée
américaine
c'était le 29 avril 1945 il y a tout
juste 75 ans en juin les français
découvrait l'horreur grâce à ce
reportage d actualité française est
faussée qui traverse le camp ont retirés
chaque jour des cadart ce qui précipite
lan des nazis ou tout simplement le
désespoir dachau le tout premier camp de
concentration nazi en 1933 il est
construit à quelques kilomètres de
munich au sud de l'allemagne
dès le départ des opposants au régime
d'hitler ils sont internés des
persécutés
c'était un bon camp établi avant la
guerre pour les anti nazi invoquant pour
lequel les nazis avaient prévu un longue
à venir
l'avenir de ces détenus étaient lui
strictement limitées après les opposants
politiques arrivent des déportés ratio
juifs tziganes mais aussi homosexuels
ont été nombreux à franchir les portes
du camp bulgares roumains hongrois
polonais soviétique l'europe agressé
suite ici mutilé seigner beaucoup
d'entre eux ont été victimes de torture
et des expérimentations médicales en
tout genre notamment des femmes des
atrocités filmée par des correspondants
de guerre français à la libération du
camp
attention les images peuvent choquer
l'une servette aux expériences de
fécondation artificielle à l'autre on
faisait en une seule semaine cinq
prélèvements de moelle épinière
d'autres étaient le sujet d'étude sur
l'intensité des brûlures au phosphore
après la libération vient le temps de la
mémoire et de sa transmission aux
générations futures
en 1965 un musée et un mémorial sont
inaugurées dans le camp
une initiative prise par d'anciens
survivants en plus de ces lieux de
mémoire d'anciens déportés viennent
aussi témoigner des horreurs de dachau
parmi eux
l'accordéoniste et ancien résistant
andré verchuren en 1966 4 est quand même
qu'à 13h au sepa concept en 1995 autre
témoignage pour la première fois depuis
sa déportation un ancien maquisard
bretons revenaient sur les lieux des
paroles poignantes à l'occasion du 50e
anniversaire de la libération du camp
quand il partait à la mort y lisait
vivait longtemps depuis longtemps et
toutes étaient brouillées pour nous pour
que au total plus de 200 mille personnes
de 30 pays différents ont été déportés
dans ce camp selon le mémorial de dachau
41500 et sont mortes
[Musique]